it's one of the biggest apps in the
world that is using Tick Tock a security
risk hi bestie I hope you have the most
wonderful day this is an issue of our
times Sophie get off it stop it
[Music]
tick tock is owned by the Chinese tech
company bite dance some fear that the
app can Harvest your data and
potentially hand it to the Chinese
government
for people with sensitive information on
their phones for example government
workers it could mean a potentially
major security risk
we'll look back at this time and say wow
that was a really
uh naive time where people just let
their data go all over the place so at a
time when tensions between China and the
West is high and governments are
cracking down and banning workers from
having the app on their work phones my
words
government workers in more than half of
the U.S states Canada and the European
commission are all banned from having
Tech talk on their work devices the
measuring swing line with our strict
internal cyber security policies the U.S
House Foreign Affairs committee even
voted to give President Biden the power
to ban the app altogether it's something
his predecessor Donald Trump attempted
to do in 2020. I set a date of around
September 15th at which point it's going
to be out of business in the United
States tiktok was also completely banned
in India in 2020 along with a host of
other chinese-owned apps
the UK has not put in place these type
of restrictions yet but some MPS are
worried about Tick-Tock it always blows
my mind when I look at you know the
number of people who use tick tock I
mean I'm one of them right you know use
the sort of videos are we being a bit
Sophie get off it stop it our data is a
key vulnerability and China is building
a tech totalitarian state on the back of
our data so we have to get far more
serious about protecting ourselves
Tick Tock denies it could be a security
risk at all after the EU commission's
ban the app's brussels-based public
policy official Caroline Greer tweeted
that the suspension is misguided and
based on fundamental misconceptions
but it seems bands like this aren't
having much of an impact on people who
use the app I used to be very concerned
about my data but
um I being on social media I think
there's a lot of companies that take
advantage of data and selling it and so
Tick Tock in my mind is just another
company doing that in the EU 125 million
people have the app while in the US it's
used by two-thirds of all teenagers
China has unsurprisingly hit back at the
bands
all this is playing out at the exact
time that tensions between China and the
West particularly America are at their
lowest end in decades issues from trade
computer chips that allegedly steal Tech
data Taiwan and the suspected Chinese
spy balloons shot down over the us
earlier this year have all strained
their relations this Tick-Tock
controversy is all part of that picture
and with the CEOs set to appear before a
U.S government committee at the end of
March it's set to roll on for some time